[音楽]
うん
これじゃあ肇社長ですされたに初めに空気んお料理の時間ですよろしくお願い致します
程度で全然二世としないんですけども珍しく
ツイッターとか見ててはこれマジでおいしそうだなっていうのを見つけたので京都作っ
てみたいと思いますネットでもめっちゃは際になって色んな人が作ってるんですけど
もうこりゃすごい発想だと思いましたランすげー
いや僕は抜けてないんですけどっ
ピーッチーズご飯というものがあ増やすんですよどんなものかといいますと
皆さんしてると思うんですけどこれ6ピースチーズありますよなんて言うとこれ6
ピースロック p 6 p でちょっと卑猥ですよねちょっと省略してここでは6 p
チーズを寄せいただきましょう loppi
いやーこれはもちろんみんな知ってるでしょうねもうなんかも普通にチーズが6ピース
入ってるだけなんですけどもなんと横手あげっ
を入れてほしい
ドロッ pc で打ち込んで楽と思わめちゃくちゃねご飯ができるらしいんでいきます
それをやってみようと思いますかノマーズ本当ならめっちゃツイッターでおいしい
おいしいみたいに言われてそのやりたくなっちゃうわけですよまあ is は全く時世
なんでしない独身なんてなぜ女なんですけども自分で作らないと作れない美味しいご飯
ってあったから
作るだ第2刷日は作っていこうと思います出会いぞん
用意するものゴッキーチーズご飯以上ですかーっと ct なるしようとか学校定まっ
たらいいねみたいなこと書いてありましたがこんなもんですねんあの頑張って料理こ
ないことはありませんこの詳しくはこれ作った方の daughter 産んで大概要
欄にありましてそちらからご覧くださいますそれを作っていきます本当カンター
そういうとき3点っていいっこれいつもくれますかね
今減ってね半分ですねパン打ってもがむずいなん
すまーた別注もぐらいなんじゃないでしょうか訳わかんな
そしてまず炊くために水を15分のところまで入れましょう
[音楽]
はいこんなんかなーたいとしてここからね6 p チーズ全部こう言いましょう
うわぁ子供を聞いて6 p チーズ美味しいんですよね入れのすごいな香里奈大学なる
ようが浪費じゃあ入れますったをご覧ください完全に入ってしまいました
これを得ながら書きますこーわースロットいい
ていた
ヨシュアずはたきます
[音楽]
やべ
3年ぶりにタイターまずま
はいというわけで1時間経ちました暇すぎて
お風呂入っちゃいましたジョイでもこんだけで多く pg 付ファンが観戦していると
いうわけなんですけども早速見てみようと思います
をは感持っ
ず持つクラブだが g a 5判に乗った今天是のまず大事とか言ったんじゃなんか
すぐ固まっちゃうからすごいすごいすごいすごいごはんとチーズが混ざったらまあ
なんかめっちゃいい風にマチルダ
これいやいやこれはヤバいでしょよっしゃーもう何も言わずともわかるでしょ
絶対言えばいいですうわーもうこれで襲って感じがうまそうやない
んこれ
こっちらが史上最強6 p チーズご飯でございます3グリ使われたミルキーな6 p
社のチーズがしっかりとご飯にまとわりつき
など病みつきになること間違い無しらしいですねあの僕ここあんな大人にねどこで取れ
ばいいかわかんないんですよねここで行くここで食べをさっそく食べてみようと思い
ます
[音楽]
ゴリエ
そうないただきます
うん
ああダメだこれサイゼリヤのドリアの味がするマジウメモドキ
あとええええ例えばしようと本当に高させても美味しいらしいんですよ
大コケかてくれたしてみますこんそめてなんだっても全然て構造でた仕方がわからん
[音楽]
家をおいしくなって書いてありましたん
厚木ついていただきます
ん
me
お店がもうお店のミサ
今目の前がアウターやばいやばいやばいこれ塩かけたのだとか美味しいかもですね病院
として成立しをかけた方が
でなぜか pot 6 p チーズにハーフターンに限るミートソースかけるとか
めちゃくちゃおいしくなるって書いてあったらそれやってみましょうか
みーとさん準備しましたこれこれやばいが現実に帰れないめちゃくちゃ危険なおいしい
ものを作ろうとするとかできます
[音楽]
与えてこんな文字位置がするこれがもうね位はミートソースドリアみたいになってる
わけですよます
[音楽]
印税で食ってきた米込んで一番街馬
まじかこの a 冗談時おいしいんですけどないというわけでちょっとまだ残ってるん
ですよ6 p チーズご飯で私知っておりますぅミートソースかけておいしくなると
いうことがカレーライスを作っても美味しくなると思うんですよつづく絡み合ってそれ
はのチーズカレーになると思ってい
てみあ車検をもうすてねこっ
ほど米最強かさてははいもうなくなりましたじゃない
そしてこのご覧に甘口のカレーが出てきます
はい宇宙の完成ですこれは行ったんでしょおっとっとチーズカレーめちゃくちゃ好きな
んですよそのチーズがもうないして噛みついてる時点でもめちゃくちゃおいしいと思う
んですよこれこれはいかんものを作ってしまったなぁ
いただきます
[音楽]
ああ
やっぱりと世界中まあこれねーチーズ好きかすると震えるねこれを目指し熱いた時なん
ですけど半に含まれているチーズ量の安心感が凄いですよねっと精神安定剤ために
めちゃくちゃないが食べてて安心するんですよ
これだとやめだか自分が料理うまいって漢字が入ったんですけどうーんいやーこれウ
ルー
[音楽]
ブーブーてみてください pou dou dou